Адвокат Станіслав Батрин став відомим завдяки тому,
що через суд вимагав підвищити розмір споживчого кошика
для українців. Кабмін не переглядав його понад 15 років,
і рік тому, встановив мінімалки,
виходячи із уже не існуючих цін.
Питання йде про людську гідність,
тому що держава вважає, що тобі достатньо 1600 грн,
щоб ти почувався гідним власником
українського паспорта. Я вважаю, що ні.
Справу проти Кабміну адвокат виграв,
однак уряд згодом вирішив її оскаржити. І вже півроку вона
припадає пилом в окружному адміністративному суді Києва.
Утім, Станіслава це
не демотивувало. Радше навпаки. Нині адвокат активно
розвиває проект "Відкритий суд" - відеомоніторинг
відкритих судових засідань.
ми хочемо запровадити таке
відчуття у будь-якого судді, прокурора, чи адвоката, що у процесі,
що будь-які його дії, є частиною
його відповідальності у майбутньому.
Батрин та молоді юристи відвідують звичайні слухання звичайних українців,
куди навряд чи прийдуть журналісти. Вони не лише знімають
і оприлюднюють перебіг слухань, а й накопичують відеодосьє
на суддів, прокурорів та адвокатів.
Показують їхню непідготовленість до слухань.
Непрофесійність та тих, хто порушує суддівську етику.
Таких відео у проекті "Відкритий суд" вже понад 5 тисяч.
Проект існує вже другий рік. Активісти вже не раз без попереджень
бували й на засіданнях закарпатського судді
Констанції Бенци.
Через поведінку її колеги, відео потрапило до рейтингів антигероїв.
Ти може тримаєш себе не те що в якихось рамках,
але ти розумієш,
що тебе будуть висвітлювати,  що на тебе будуть дивитись
багато громадян
і я думаю, що це позитивно
Ставати чиновником чи політиком Станіслав не збирається.
З владою в нього навпаки - постійний конфлікт. Вже другий рік
триває розгляд його заяви про встановлення факту збройної агресії
Росії проти України. Адміністрація президента та МВС
відмовляються задовольнити цю заяву.
Та Станіслава це не спиняє.
Сьогодні багато людей, тисячі людей
приймають для себе життєві рішення
і виїжджають за межі України.
Я все ж таки думаю, що це не правильний крок,
я думаю, що якщо ми хочемо зберегти Україну і
дати майбутнє нашим дітям, ми маємо відповідально
приймати і рішення і залишатись тут.
У кабінеті Станіслава чимало подяк та нагород.
Та найбільше цінує ту, яку посмертно отримав його батько,
теж адвокат, який мріяв про гідне  правосуддя
для українців.
якщо поряд працюють не кваліфіковані прокурори,
судді, юристи,
то це зачіпає мене, тому що я прагнув цього
як мінімум десять років.
Я прагнув, щоби опинитись в цій професії.
Зачіпає і змушує рухатись це відчуття цієї справедливості,
що ми мусимо це змінити.
Власне, заради цього Станіслав і здійснює такі проекти,
як "Відкритий суд". У планах - зробити відеодосьє
на кожного з восьми тисяч українських суддів.
Адвокат мріє про час, коли представники правосуддя
асоціюватимуться не з корупцією, а стануть
моральними авторитетами.